mon père est décédé mardi comment ça
votre père est décédé
des suites de ses blessures
et il n'a pas absorbé le choc par les
biens
c'est quand vous êtes venu ce que vous
me disiez 92 ans
c'est triste c'est plus que triste c'est
plus que triste
j'ai jamais autant pleuré de ma vie je
n'ai jamais pleuré auparavant et là j'ai
pleuré toutes mes larmes pendant un mois
et demi
monsieur le ministre vous écoutant il me
semble que vous avez un fort potentiel
intellectuel et vous en plus je me
semble aussi que vous êtes doté d'un
sens d'anticipation assez aiguë
et aussi
une force à comment on dirait-je vous
êtes capable de d'avoir du bon sens
alors ma question est
que s'est-il passé lorsque vous avez
installé
l'antre du diable square force Val que
s'est-il passé
pour que vous nous laissiez pendant un
an dans la peur face au crime avoir la
peur de sortir ses enfants les
accompagner au métro avoir la peur de
recevoir un coup de cutter avoir la peur
de se faire suriner par un
tournevis
ah non ça a duré la conséquence mon père
en est mort
pourquoi
voilà ma question
d'abord j'ai été évidemment bouleversé
puis quand une riveraine m'a dit parce
que on a échangé quand je suis venu je
suis plusieurs fois sur le site du crack
comme on l'appelle force Val et une dame
à qui j'ai laissé mon numéro de
téléphone m'a dit le jour votre papa est
décédé
je me suis senti responsable évidemment
puisque j'ai beaucoup d'agressions qui
venaient de 50 sur cheval alors faut que
chacun comprenne ce qui s'est passé
parce que monsieur vous le connaissez ça
avait peut-être je sais pas si tous les
Français le savent il y a du crack
depuis 40 ans à Paris mais depuis
quelques années
ça c'est un film qui s'est
[Musique]
développé encore plus et ils étaient
d'abord dans une première partie à
Stalingrad
et je n'ai beaucoup beaucoup les
riverains et beaucoup d'agressions
beaucoup d'agressions sexuelles beaucoup
de tentatives domicile à Stalingrad et
la mairie de Paris a déplacé dans un
square un jardin et amis toutes ces
personnes qui sont pour une partie
extrêmement dépendante d'une drogue qui
rend fou il y a pas d'autres mots et qui
sont très malades avec tout ce que ça
comporte comme
acte évidemment criminel sans au Square
de la Villette et là encore puisqu'on a
déplacé le problème il y a des riverains
il y a des gens qui connaissaient les
mêmes choses si j'ose dire que vous mais
pas à ce point bien évidemment monsieur
et donc le préfet de police précédent a
pris avec mon autorisation
le choix d'essayer de trouver un autre
terrain on a trouvé c'est trouvé des
terrains un peu partout dans des décès
de la SNCF on a pensé un terrain dans le
12e enfin voilà pas à Paris c'est pas
très évident de trouver un grand terrain
pour mettre tous ces gens
puisque le grand problème c'est pas
tellement un problème de police que
sanitaire il faut soigner ces gens pour
une partie de ceux qui peuvent être
soignés et puis c'était un personne n'a
voulu te ces personnes et donc dans
l'endroit le moins je sais que pour vous
ça va pas vous plaire évidemment cette
phrase mais le moins gênant on a mis à
force valve ces personnes là en disant
la ville de Paris en disant à la région
Île-de-France en disant à l'agence
régionale de santé en disant en médecin
il faut que vous preniez des décisions
pour mettre ces personnes en dehors de
la voie publique pour les soigner comme
on fait avec des gens qui sont fous on
les enfer dans les hôpitaux
psychiatriques et ben moi je pense que
les gens qui sont drogués à ce point au
crack il faut des injonctions
thérapeutiques et enfermée le temps de
la thérapie quand on peut faire une
thérapie en général les gens qui
consomment du crack ils ont l'espérance
de vie d'un an et demi deux ans
et puis c'est pas venu donc on avait
donné un premier délai un deuxième délai
c'est pas venu vous avez vu les
difficultés qu'on a avec les élus c'est
très compliqué pour eux aussi moi je
jette pas le problème et puis on a eu un
nouveau préfet de police et moi j'ai
j'ai dit dès le mois d'août après fait
de police vous avez un mois et demi pour
non pas déplacer mais pour dégager tout
le monde quand on est intervenu on a
interpellé plus de 350 personnes
les plus faibles parce que les autres
ont été prévenus par des associations et
ce qui fait que vous n'avez pas pu faire
votre travail alors c'est pas tout à
fait vrai si vous permettez ce jour-là
oui vous avez raison mais vous savez on
a pris 1000 policiers pour faire cette
opération donc quand on fait 1000
policiers un secret gardé par 1000
personnes c'est pas très évident donc je
regrette que les gens parlent mais enfin
je le savais un peu quand on intervie il
y avait quand même 300 personnes sur
site j'ai pu mettre monsieur on va
parler tout à l'heure plus de 80
étrangers en situation régulière dans
des centres de rétention administratif
physique sont aujourd'hui on a réussi à
expulser de nouvelles personnes
d'ailleurs dans des pays notamment
d'Afrique puisque une grande partie sont
des ressortissants d'Afrique on a pu
monsieur faire 112 interpellations
depuis 15 jours puisque les gens
reviennent sur site notamment des mots
doux des trafiquants qui sont sans garde
à vue soit en prison et donc il y a une
ouverture aujourd'hui à chaque fois
d'enquête judiciaire ce matin je suis
allé Aubervilliers pour parce qu'il y a
pas que Paris il y avait Aubervilliers
il y avait pantin bien évidemment qui
subissaient ce que vous avez dit donc on
n'a pas choisi de déplacer une nouvelle
fois le site on a choisi de faire un
travail un peu tout seul je veux bien
l'avouer au ministère de l'Intérieur
vous avez tapé un coup de pied dans la
fourmilière mais moi ce que je veux dire
mais les fourmis vont revenir alors ils
ne reviendront pas parce que c'est 1000
policiers monsieur vous devez les voir
j'espère j'y vais souvent aller voir
aussi même discrètement ils sont
toujours là entre Stalingrad le 19e
arrondissement pantin Aubervilliers sont
toujours là la mère debervilliers est
juste pas ton téléphone m'a dit après
m'avoir beaucoup disputé oui c'est vrai
qu'on voit du mieux je laisserai les
policiers monsieur autant qu'il le
faudra mais je veux dire à la ville de
Paris je veux dire au monde médical je
veux dire au monde associatif aussi que
ils doivent trouver des solutions qui ne
sont pas avec des solutions policières
ce que nous on arrête les gens on les
met en garde à vue et c'est travail du
policier il travaille policier c'est pas
d'être médecin c'est pas de faire un
logement social c'est un travail de
policiers et je peux vous assurer
monsieur que toutes les semaines je vole
préfet de police et préfet de la région
Île-de-France et que tous les 15 jours
j'irai sur site tant qu'on a pas réglé
ce problème donc vous avez eu un long
échange avec Madame Hidalgo dont je
souhaite j'espère et je sais qu'elle
sera enfin des solutions avec l'État et
moi je vais vous dire qu'effectivement
on a trop tardé à le faire j'ai
peut-être mis trop de temps monsieur à
attendre de tout le monde qu'il
réagissent mais au bout d'un temps dont
l'agression de votre repère a fait
partie de mes décisions je me suis dit
on peut pas continuer comme ça en effet
vous avez parfaitement raison la sans
doute trop tardé mais c'est évidemment
toujours compliqué pour ce genre de
choix parce que j'étais aussi très
critiqué vous savez le faire il y a des
gens qui m'ont dit vous vous interpellez
les drogués au lieu de soigner bah oui
on fait une réponse policière au lieu de
faire des réponses sanitaire c'est tout
à fait vrai et donc aujourd'hui je mets
la pression au maximum et mise à la
santé mettent beaucoup pour ça il y a
une deuxième chose que je pousse c'est
que dans la loi monsieur ce
qu'aujourd'hui je n'ai pas le droit de
le faire moi j'applique la loi je n'ai
pas la jonction
d'enfermer les gens pour des raisons
thérapeutiques
un autre exemple quand j'étais mère
disait du bon sens les gens qui sont
fous sur la voie publique les mers ont
le droit après avis du médecin de les
mettre dans un hôpital psychiatrique ici
un document évidemment il y a un médecin
qui donne son accord avant pour le cas
des personnes très dépendantes à une
drogue comme le crack et toutes les
grandes villes du monde vous savez bien
sont comparés à cette on n'a pas la
possibilité de donner aux maires ou de
donner aux forces de police le moyen
pour des raisons d'injonction
thérapeutiques à quelqu'un qui ne veut
pas très difficilement se soigner voilà
et moi je souhaite qu'on le met dans la
loi ça pour que plus jamais on puisse
revoir
malheureusement force Val ou juste
vous racontez tout tout ce qui s'est
passé et voilà vous dites que voilà vous
auriez peut-être dû aller un petit peu
plus vite Jérôme
pour vous votre papa est parti on
Baptiste et je me rappelle quand vous
étiez venu sur le plateau vous me disiez
c'est vrai que je ne sais pas à qui vous
en vouliez le plus
aujourd'hui c'est quoi votre sentiment
monsieur Darmanin
c'est un acteur principal dans ce
meurtre mais il n'est pas coupable
mais
il aurait dû agir bien avant
Xavier la sonnette d'alarme plusieurs
fois
pas moi l'association qui est à côté de
moi oui
depuis des mois et des mois
j'ai une prière monsieur Darmanin une
prière cette prière c'est
c'est que vous vous libériez le
commissariat du 19e
de ses pinces
il me semble lorsque je vais les voir et
je les connais depuis 25 ans
ils n'ont plus les coûts
sont des gens qui ont envie vraiment de
travailler laisser les faire laissez
vraiment les faire ils savent faire leur
travail et nous allons retrouver dans le
19e
de la sérénité nos enfants pourront
enfin
se faire se promener jouer au foot comme
avant les petits vieux éviteront de se
faire tuer et les femmes vont pouvoir se
promener sans se faire agresser et
insulter s'il vous plaît monsieur
Darmanin libérez le commissariat du 19e